[Music]  [Audio Description - not captioned]
[Corey Lester, PhD] My proposal to the National
Library of Medicine was to develop and design
artificial intelligence. Specifically, a
computer vision model which could look at
a picture of pills inside a medication bottle and
accurately identify the contents of that bottle.
We are testing how that model can
be used in collaboration with the
human so that errors don't happen in the pharmacy.
[Raed Al Kontar, PhD] How do you
teach a machine - if you want to
a machine to differentiate between an
anomaly in medical dispensing or not?
What you do is - you give the
machine images of anomalies,
you give the machine images of good medications,
and you tell them - this is good, this is bad.
When the algorithm can make this link, then if
you give the algorithm a new image, the algorithm
can predict - this image belongs to which
class? Is it the good group or the bad group.
So fundamentally, it's a matching
decision done in a fancy mathematical way.
[Lester] So the way we see this being implemented
is - once we have that picture of pills in the
bottle, we can use this model to predict
what medication it is in that image and
cross-reference it with the expected or intended
medication that was supposed to be filled.
In this way, we can support pharmacists
in their double-check verification of the
patient getting the right
pill in the right bottle.
[Kontar] The results were surprisingly
positive and we found that our algorithm
can predict with an accuracy above 99.5 percent.
But what one thing that we are afraid of - even
those 0.5 percent of errors can be critical.
Our hope is that, in those cases where the
algorithm is wrong, the algorithm can tell
us that it is not confident in its results.
Then at least, the human can double-check.
[Xi Jessie Yang, PhD] Our next step is to conduct
the experiment with pharmacists and through
that we are going to track how their trust
change over time on a trial-to-trial basis.
So its through the experiment we
can collect participants responses,
their physiological signals,
and we want to use eye tracking.
And by analyzing their responses and signals,
we can track how their trust changes over time,
how their behaviors, their
performance changes over time.
[Lester] The ultimate goal of this project
is to develop safer systems that can be used
to save lives and prevent medication
errors from causing harm to patients.
[Yang] It means tons to me. As an engineer,
I believe our ultimate mission is to propose
solutions that can be used to enhance people's
life. Being part of the projects doing just that.
[Lester] The National Library
of Medicine's financial support
of this project has really been invaluable.
So really, they've been instrumental in
making all of this research possible.
[Kontar] Without it, we would not have had
the capability to collect all this data,
to do all this analysis, and generate
the promising results we have right now.
[Music continues]
[Music fades to silence]
[Silence]